this video is sponsored by brilliant org
and it's the second video in a mini
series about linear algebra click here
to watch the first one on vectors and
bases for vector spaces this video is
about matrices when I first met a matrix
it was in a textbook question it asked
me to put a bunch of numbers to do with
a bakery sales into an array I was very
confused it took me a long long time to
really understand that matrices have
nothing to do with bakeries and just the
same way that writing a vector as a
column of numbers is just a shorthand
writing a matrix as an array of numbers
is a shorthand - this is what matrices
really are they are linear
transformations okay so let me explain
remember vectors from last time well
imagine you have some vector and you
want to transform it into some other
vector instead in fact say you have some
whole vector space let's say all the
vectors in 2d space and you want to
transform them into vectors in another
or the same space for example vectors in
3d space then a transformation is
something that just eats a vector from
your initial space and spits out a
vector in your new space a matrix is a
transform but a very specific type
called a linear transform which is
something that respects linear
combinations let's say I have two
vectors I'm going to apply this matrix
to each of them and that will transform
them in some way then I can make a
linear combination of the result but
what if I decided to do this linear
combination first and then put the
resulting vector into the matrix a
linear transformation is one when these
two processes result in the same final
vector in other words you can put your
two vectors into the matrix and then
take a particular linear combination of
them or you can take that linear
combination of them first and then apply
the matrix either way you're going to
get the same result to see if you've
understood this I want you to figure out
if the following transformations are
linear or not the first is a
transformation that takes a 2d vector
and then just multiplies it by length 3
the second is like this first draw a
line through the origin then take any
vector in 2d say this one and draw a
perpendicular from that line to the tip
of the vector the new vector is on the
line so are these two linear
transformations think about the answer
and then put it in the pole in the
corner remember committing to an answer
really helps you learn
[Music]
okay so the answer might surprise you
but they're both linear to see this take
the first one take any two vectors and
apply the transformation to them and
then make a linear combination of them
this is clearly the same as if you make
the linear combination of them and then
multiply the result by three the second
one is a bit trickier but the easiest
way to see it is first draw the two
vectors then notice these vectors are
equal to these two perpendicular vectors
added together when you apply the
transform to them what it does is it
cuts off this bit then if you add them
you get this but if instead you'd added
the original vectors first it would be
like adding all four bits first which
you can group up like this
now if we apply the transformation it
cuts off this bit and as you can see we
have the same thing in both cases kind
of neat right but here's the really nice
thing about linear transformations
imagine you have a linear transformation
from some initial space to some other
space and you have an arbitrary basis
for your initial space now let's suppose
that we know exactly what the linear
transformation does to the basis vectors
this is in fact enough to figure out
what it does to the entire space to see
why say you have some other vector in
the initial space you can write it as a
linear combination of the basis vectors
in 2d remember you do this by using a
grid
okay so once you finally got that linear
combination if you apply a linear
transformation to it you can see by
linearity that you only needed to know
what happened to the basis vectors to
compute this thing so now we get to
writing a matrix as an array what you
see is the first column represents what
happens to your first basis vector the
second what happens to your second basis
vector etc remember how to write vectors
as columns in some basis it's a
shorthand for writing out this linear
combination of basis vectors then
clearly the basis vectors are written
like this say I apply my linear
transformation to the first basis
element and I get this column vector and
I do this for each basis vector as I
said before this is everything I need to
know about a linear transformation so I
want to store this information compactly
so I store it in a matrix like this and
that is all the matrix really is it's
shorthand where just like in the case of
vectors written as columns the basis is
hidden but the basis is super important
so this array of numbers only represents
a linear transformation as long as
you're clear about what the basis is now
I can explain what it means to multiply
a matrix by a vector it's not about
multiplication at all all it means is
you apply the linear transformation that
this matrix represents to the vector
that this represents
[Music]
as we saw this is equal to this big sum
which you might recognize as the rule
for multiplying matrices and vectors to
see if you've got all this see if you
can come up with a matrix for the
following linear transformation it takes
the first basis vector and does nothing
to it and takes the second basis vector
and deletes it another way of thinking
of that is it takes the second basis
vector to the zero vector the vector
with no length pause the video now and
try and come up with a matrix in this
basis so hopefully you've had a think
the answer is this by the way your
matrices definitely don't need to be
square the dimension of the matrix tell
you about the dimension of the vectors
it eats versus the dimension of the
vectors it spits out in this example the
matrix takes 3d vectors and gives back
2d ones then its shape has to be this
because it has three rows representing
what the matrix does to the three basis
vectors of the initial space and two
columns because each of the basis
vectors becomes a 2d vector if you
followed everything so far then matrix
multiplication is going to be really
simple to explain you know how when you
first meet matrix multiplication
they throw this crazy formula at you
then they expect you to act shocked when
you find out that if you call this
insane thing multiplication then a times
B doesn't equal B times a there is a
much much easier way to understand
matrix multiplication let's look at an
example first imagine you want to
transform some vectors
first you want to rotate them by 90
degrees in the plane then you want to
project them onto this line like we did
earlier
both of these are linear so call the
matrix representing these
transformations in some basis a and B
then here's a question is it the same
thing to do the projection first and
then the rotation I can tell you it's
not but I want you to pause the video
now and think of a vector that would
come out different if you do the
projection first or if you do it second
if you can think of one say-so in the
pole here okay so there are many options
but here's a vector that works if a
vector starts on the line and you apply
a it gets rotated to here but then you
apply B to the result and you project it
down so in this case it immediately
becomes the zero vector but if you did
it the other way around when you apply B
nothing happens and then when you apply
a it gets rotated to here so clearly
doing a then B is different from doing B
then a so here's the big secret when we
write be a the linear transformation
that we're talking about is the one
where you do a first then B that's all
it means and as we've just seen oughta
matters so this is clearly different
from the linear transformation a B since
in that case you swap the order so the
statement a B doesn't equal B a is
actually blindingly obvious once you
understand the meaning of these things
and really shouldn't be presented as a
startling fact so why does this lovely
idea of composing Maps lead to the
awfulness that is the matrix
multiplication formula well actually
once you understand it the formula
really isn't ugly at all let me show you
what I mean by taking the case where a
and B are 2 by 2 matrices
how would we try and write a B as a
matrix in a particular basis well let's
just follow our own rules we need to
find out what a B does to each of the
basis vectors let's do the first one
well when we apply B we get the first
column of B by definition but then we
apply a and we get B 1 1 times the first
column of a plus B 2 1 times the second
column this result is our first column
of a B do the same for the second basis
vector and here is the formula C
matrices aren't so painful after all
okay so it's homework time first not all
size matrices can be multiplied together
think about it in terms of them
representing transformations from one
space to another and figure out which
size matrices can be multiplied and
explain why in the comments second and
this is a multiple choice one consider a
transformation that takes a 3d vector
and add some fixed vector K to it say K
is the vector 7 3 3 is this a linear
transformation or not
third imagine you have a matrix a that
multiplies the first basis vector by two
and the second basis vector by six how
do you write a e in this basis
as you will have noticed these questions
are from brilliant org who are
sponsoring this video I said this last
time but I think linear algebra is just
a topic that you can't understand
without doing examples if you try and
understand the topics through just
learning a bunch of formulas or theorems
you just won't be able to get all the
subtleties involved I found that when I
went through brilliants course which has
really well-designed examples I
remembered a bunch of tricky little
points that I'd forgotten about and it
got me really comfortable with doing
actual calculations again since I don't
do a lot of those anymore you can sign
up to either a monthly or a yearly
membership and access this course and
many others on their website if you
follow the link on the screen or in the
description you can get 20% off your
yearly membership thanks for watching
these linear algebra videos it's one of
my favorite fields of maths so I love
teaching it because it feels like I'm
learning it all again myself anyway the
next one will be linked here in two
weeks so subscribe if you'd like to see
it when that's out
you